この系つになると空気は乾燥し肌も乾燥
心も感想全体的にカサカサですはじめ社長ですこの地図になると空気が乾燥するので
部屋で加湿器を使う方が多いと思いますこちらが僕が使ったり加湿器なんですけど
いうこれはこれも勝つ的なんですけどもこれプラズマクラスターって言ってウィリスと
がカビを退治してくれる施工いい奴ですかし次ってどうやって使うかと言いますとこの
ねファンクこのタンクの中に水を入れて中に入れてボタンを押すと
仮説が集まるということでございます私は思ってしまったこの仮説基のタンクでお咲を
入れたらどうなるのか
こうじろ普段雨でを下げたがないんでよくわからないんですけどなんかこれではがそう
だよねアルコールが20%っていう結構高いんですよねかなりアルコール濃度が高い
ですこのお酒
を未成年のみんなはのんざが女だぞ
ねぇ本当のんずダメだからね店んじゃないと買うことも許されないからな
あれを意外とおいしいねこれ大人になっているので意外と美味しいんだけど
あっチリ全然だ村にがりやうううううと言うけど見てのとで僕がの桜さてが基本的に
苦手なんですよなんとかもうもう彼は各ねもうか若いんですけど僕何とかしてお酒をの
場図にこのよっ漂った感じを楽しみたいと思ったんで今回加湿器にを下げてお酒で兵を
加湿したらちょっとしてお酒を飲まなくてもその歌詞付き
だけでを得るんじゃないかと思いましてすと今回は実際にそれを試してみると思います
要するにこの部屋全体にこの下げの成分を1渡らせるということだから
[音楽]
マースターズ入れる
これねまず純正に気になるこれでもし終えたらすげー楽じゃん先ほど持てばが省けると
いう何かしながら良いるっていうソースの加湿器がぶっ壊れ頃加えないかっていうと
困ると思うんですけどもまぁそこはやってみてのお楽しみにしましょうと言って早速
加湿していきましょう
いくぞスイッチ
パスは max にしておきましょう
ブーブー ore
あっひっ
うすげー匂いするに置いたようわーうわーすげー
お酒飲んじゃい隠れちゃんとすぎる除去しますただこれでこの部屋中にアルコールが
まき散らされるかどうかっていうとまだわかんないんでしばらく放置して本当にこれで
この部屋がアルコール褒めでになるかっていうとちょっと喋りことだろうます知らせ
おもちゃ
ん
[音楽]
ああああああ
すごいすごいすごいすごいうわーーー
パンッうわっふおおうわああ
わーもうちょいできるあれすごい以後エンサーの多分コレ
まあこれやばいんだから冷えずにアルコールが散らばってる背景でかつてするとかなり
毛ずがもうお酒を割ることにおいでまた終わることが分かりました
またに今回さらにこちらアンコールどんど96%地上最強の席スペイン達夫
お腹に入れて排出しようと思ったんですけども
やばいなと思ってネットで色々調べたんですけどもアルコールというかでお酒を聞か
するのはかなり危ないらしい
幸次郎ぐらいなら別に大丈夫なんですけどこのスピリーですねこれアルコール濃度
96%なんでほぼお酒じゃなくてもアルコールなんですねこのまま僕化し次に入れて
この液体を帰化させて部屋頭やアルコールを待っ飛ばして
僕が入って数とアルコール中毒で僕多分
色々調べたんですけどもこのアルコールを聞かされるとそれ数だけで数だけでやっぱ
酔うらしくてその酔うのがその良いのかね普通にお酒をの分より1.4倍くらい早い
らしくてね闘争方ですけど入って4倍くらい速いらしいんで結構危険らしいですして
スピード差なんかお菓子ってすると部屋ずすげーどうぞアルコールで満たされるんで
本当にある
通読でかなり危険だ状態らしいのでやめておきますまるで
どこかの事件で使われるトリックみたいだお酒を貸し付けに入れて走ってすると意外と
部屋塩酒になるんですけどもう通常にも酔いやすいのでかなり
やる人は気をつけてみてくださいスミせねーよだめだぞ
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ
[音楽]
ぱーぱぱんわー
うツアーうわぁ